EMIL KINER: Hi, my
name is Emil Kiner.
I'm the product manager
for Google Cloud
Armor on the network security
product team at Google Cloud.
Today, I'll be talking
to you about how
to protect your applications
from distributed
denial of service attacks
as well as targeted web
attacks using Cloud Armor.
We'll start off with an
overview of network security
in general on Google Cloud.
From there, we'll
discuss all the latest
and greatest
announcements and new
features that we've
launched for Cloud Armor
over the past several months.
After that, we'll dive
in and discuss in depth
how application protection
and DDoS defense works.
And then we'll
discuss some customer
use cases about how to
protect your applications
in real-world scenarios.
Security follows a shared
responsibility model
on Google Cloud.
We work to secure our
network and infrastructure
and provide customers the
tools necessary to do so
in their own projects.
We enable and
encourage customers
to follow a defense-in-depth
approach and deploy security
controls at various levels of
their stack and infrastructure
to enforce access
controls and ensure data
and mission-critical workloads
remain private and secure.
On Google Cloud, we have several
key network security controls.
Starting from the outside
in, we have Cloud Armor,
the identity aware proxy,
and the global load
balancers as our
layer 7 controls
at the edge of the network.
Cloud Armor, in conjunction
with the global LBs,
protect applications
from DDoS attacks.
The Identity Aware Proxy is
part of our BeyondCorp line
of products to allow access
to internal applications
without needing a VPN.
Firewalls, in red,
apply at the VPC level
and can be used to customize
access for north-south traffic
as well as east-west traffic
into, out of, or through VPCs.
Firewalls are used to
define VPC boundaries
but can be as
granular as per host.
VPC Service Controls,
in blue, can
be used to control access
to and from GCP services
and managed APIs, such as
BigQuery or Cloud Storage
to or from the internet,
VPCs, or on-premise sources.
In yellow, we have
packet mirroring
that allows you to deploy a tap
and mirror packets at the VM
or container cluster boundary
to a configurable collector
destination.
Finally, we also support
sending outbound traffic
through Cloud NAT as well as
various interconnected VPN
options to enhance
privacy and security.
Cloud load balancing
is a critical component
of the end-to-end
network security story.
We have three flavors of global
load balancing-- the HTTPS load
balancer, the SSL proxy,
and the TCP proxy.
The first two load
balancers are SSL
terminating, meaning you
are able to offload the SSL
termination and decryption
to our edge proxies,
and we'll handle enforcing
SSL policies upstream
of your infrastructure.
By uploading your certificates
and configuring custom SSL
policies, you can ensure
only pre-approved SSL/TLS
versions and ciphers are
allowed on a per-VIP basis.
All of the global
load balancers employ
a two-tier global anycast
based system rather than
a DNS-based load
balancing mechanism.
We broadcast the load
bouncer's IP address globally,
and end user requests
are routed to
and terminated at the
geographically nearest point
of presence, or POP, to them.
From there, the request
is coalesced and proxied
over Google's fiber backbone
to the customer backend
in the geographically nearest
region with available capacity.
At each stage of the process,
we optimize on latency,
taking into account capacity
if the underlying application
is deployed across
multiple regions.
Cloud Armor is the web
application firewall and DDoS
mitigation service,
able to provide layer
7 protection and filtering
for workloads deployed on GCP,
on prem, or with other
infrastructure providers.
Cloud Armor is deeply integrated
with the global load balancing
infrastructure and is
able to inspect and filter
incoming requests after the
SSL termination has occurred.
More specifically,
with Cloud Armor,
customers are able to protect
their HTTP-fronted applications
from DDos attack, filter
incoming requests by geography,
or most L7 parameters, like
request headers or cookies.
Moreover, as a
web-application firewall,
Cloud Armor contains
pre-configured rules
to prevent against the
most common attacks
and vulnerability
exploit attempts.
Users have access to
real-time telemetry
in the form of logs sent
to Cloud Logging containing
Cloud Armor's decisions
on a per-request basis;
a monitoring
dashboard that gives
granular views of allowed,
denied, or previewed traffic;
as well as a
correlated WAF security
findings that are sent to the
Cloud Security Command Center.
As of March of this
year, a rich set
of WAF capabilities
for Cloud Armor
was made generally available.
Preconfigured rules
can help mitigate
the OWASP top 10 risks.
We have ported over the
mod security core rule set,
introducing rules
to detect and block
SQL injection and cross-site
scripting attempts as generally
available.
Additionally, rules for local
file inclusion, remote file
inclusion, and
remote code execution
are available as a beta.
The rest of the core rule
set is targeted for release
over the course of this year.
With geo-based rules, customers
can enforce access controls
based on the source
geography of each request.
The IP-to-geo mappings are
sourced from Google's own geo
team, so you can be
sure of its accuracy.
We've also launched an
extensible rules language
that allows users to configure
custom layer 7 filtering
policies across request
headers, request
parameters, and cookies.
Finally, Cloud Armor is now
integrated with the Security
Command Center with
Cloud Armor findings
as well as assets being
sent to the CSCC dashboard
to alert defenders
of potential attacks
against protected
applications and websites.
We have recently
greatly increased
the flexibility of
Cloud Armor deployments
to protect an expanded set
of customer infrastructure
on GCP as well as in hybrid
use cases located on prem
or in other cloud providers.
Cloud Armor now supports
protecting cloud CDM origin
servers by enforcing security
policies on dynamic requests,
as well as cache misses destined
for the CDM origin server.
Customer applications
are often complex,
serving both cacheable
static content as well as
dynamic requests from
the same services.
With Cloud Armor able to
inspect and filter requests
destined to CDN origin servers.
Users can now mitigate
computationally expensive cache
busting attacks, as
well as help protect
dynamic portions of
websites and applications
from OWASP's top 10 risks.
Enterprises often need to
enforce a consistent set
of security controls
for their applications,
no matter where they are
deployed, whether they
are migrating to GCP or
running in permanently hybrid
configurations.
We recently launched support
for internet network and point
groups that allows customers to
leverage all of Google's Edge
infrastructure, including
cloud load balancers, Cloud
CDM, and Cloud Armor to protect
their website or application,
no matter where they are hosted.
Now Google can help
protect year applications,
whether from DDoS attacks
or other common web
attacks without having to
deploy the application directly
on GCP.
Finally, GKE ingress support
for Cloud Armor has recently
reached general availability.
GKE users can help protect
their containerized workloads
by placing them behind
the cloud load balancers
and configuring the Cloud Armor
security policy for layer 7
filtering and WAF use cases.
Also we are proud to
announce the availability
as a beta, a highly
requested capability
to allow or deny traffic
through a Cloud Armor security
policy based on a
pre-configured, named IP list.
Many of our customers receive
traffic into their GCP projects
from upstream service
providers, such as other CDMs.
Prior to this
capability, customers
would have to self-manage
the list of IPs
from upstream
providers to ensure
they can receive those requests
through a Cloud Armor security
policy.
Now customers can
configure a security policy
to deny all traffic from
the internet by default
and allow only traffic
from desired IP ranges
by referencing the
named IP lists.
For now, the named IP
lists are global in nature
and not user defined.
We are launching the beta
with three launch partners--
Fastly, Cloudflare,
and Imperva--
but intend to add the other
service providers over time.
Finally, we are excited
and proud to announce
the beta launch of Cloud
Armor Managed Protection,
a set of DDoS mitigation
and WAF services
offered at two service
tiers, standard and plus,
which bundles together all of
the features and capabilities
of Cloud Armor with additional
value-added services,
all for an enterprise
friendly, predictable
monthly subscription.
Last month, we published
a blog post announcing
that Google had successfully
detected and mitigated
the largest DDoS attack
ever recorded to date.
Now, with managed protection
Google Cloud customers
can leverage the same
Edge capacity as well as
DDoS defense expertise to
protect their own applications
and other publicly
exposed workloads,
with a subscription plan
that offers enterprise
friendly and
critically predictable
pricing, which is not driven
by incoming request volumes.
Cloud Armor WAF usage
includes rules, policies,
and requests are included
in the subscription plan,
meaning Cloud Armor monthly
price will remain relatively
fixed, even if you are targeted
by a high-volume layer 7 DDoS
attack that needs to be
mitigated by Cloud Armor.
Over time, we will
expand the services
offered in the
plus tier, starting
with the upcoming
Google-curated rule sets,
like the named IP lists
announced previously.
For more information
on managed protection,
please refer to the Cloud
Armor blog announcing the beta,
as well as the product
page for a sign-up form
to get more information.
On GCP, customers enjoy
an unrivaled level
of DDoS protection from a
wide variety of attack types.
It is important to understand
that DDoS protection cloud
customers are able to
receive is the same that
has been developed
over the past 20 years
to protect and
ensure availability
of Google's own services.
Thanks to the global
nature of Google's network,
we are able to absorb and
dissipate or otherwise
mitigate layer 3 and layer 4
network or volumetric attacks
across various components
in our global load balancing
infrastructure.
The way this automatic
mitigation works
is that all three types
of global load balancers
will only proxy requests
back to the customer backend
service when that request
has completed a three-way TCP
handshake.
For volumetric and
protocol-based DDoS attacks,
like UDP amplification
or reflection, as well as
TCP floods, the TCP handshake
is actually never established,
so we can safely drop this
unwelcome traffic far upstream
of your infrastructure.
This happens
automatically upstream
of customer infrastructure.
Next, Cloud Armor
security policies
can be configured and
attached to the load balanced
backend services
to further provide
layer 7 application layer
protection and access controls.
Cloud Armor security
policies can
be configured to
limit access based
on source IP or geo, a
pre-configured WAF rule set,
as well as our fully
customizable rules language
to craft custom layer
7 filtering policies.
Diving in a bit further,
Cloud Armor security policies
can simultaneously invoke
pre-configured WAF rules,
as well as user-defined rules
to inspect request headers,
parameters, and cookies.
Policies are stored,
evaluated, and enforced
at the edge of Google's network
far upstream of customer's
infrastructure.
In the example on this
slide, we have a policy
that first denies access to
any external clients requesting
access to the admin portal
of our example application.
Next, the Cloud
Armor security policy
is configured to invoke
preconfigured WAF rules
to detect and block known
signatures for SQL injection
and cross-site
scripting attacks,
which collectively have
dozens of subsignatures
under the hood.
Finally, if the
request is neither
targeting the admin
portal nor containing
a SQL injection or cross-site
scripting signature,
we will allow that
traffic as configured
through the default rule.
Now, we'll discuss some example
use cases for how customers
can protect their applications.
In order to protect
your application
from volumetric and
protocol-based DDoS attacks,
all that is necessary is to
deploy one of the global load
balancers in front of
your HTTP or TCP workload.
Once fronted by the load
balancers, Cloud Armor,
in conjunction with the
LDs, will automatically
mitigate DDoS attacks like
DNS amplification attacks,
SYN floods, and other common
layer 3, layer 4 DDoS attacks.
The only requests that will be
proxy back to your applications
are ones that have completed
the three-way handshake
and are well-formed
layer 7 requests.
To add layer 7 protection
for your applications,
the first thing you need to
do is configure a Cloud Armor
security policy and attach it
to the backend service that
is hosting the application
or workload to be protected.
Cloud Armor security policies
are used to customize access
to protected resources.
There is a one-to-many
relationship between policies
and backends, meaning
one policy can
be attached to multiple
backend services,
but each backend can only have
one security policy protecting
it.
Each policy consists of a
prioritized list of rules
as well as a default rule.
As an incoming request tries
to reach the customer backend
service, Cloud Armor
will evaluate each rule
in priority order
against the traffic.
The first matching
rule will win,
meaning it will dictate
the action to take--
allow or deny in this case.
If the traffic doesn't
match any rules,
then the action configured
with the default rule
will be applied to
either allow or deny
the traffic through to
the targeted backend.
Visibility and
telemetry is key for
any comprehensive application
protection solution.
Cloud Armor exposes
this information
in near real time across
several telemetry platforms
at Google Cloud.
Per-request logs are
captured and sent
to Cloud Logging
containing all decisions
that Cloud Armor makes with
regard to layer 7 requests,
as well as which
rules fired and why.
Real-time telemetry
for request volumes
is available at various
levels of granularity
through cloud monitoring in
our preconfigured dashboard
to help you visualize
and build the learning
policies against changes
in traffic patterns.
Finally, correlated
security findings
about unexpected
traffic spikes are
sent to the Security
Command Center
to trigger investigation
and possibly
incident response workflows.
Putting it all together,
here is an example
of a sophisticated use case
that leverages the ability
to dynamically update
Cloud Armor security
policies through our feature
rich REST API or CLI.
Here, we see an application
fronted by a cloud load
balancer with Google
Cloud Armor enabled.
Telemetry is collected until
monitoring and analytics
workflow, either
homegrown by the customer,
commercial off-the-shelf,
or using GCP's native data
analytics tools,
such as BigQuery.
Other sources of
telemetry and logging
are added to the system,
including from the application,
from Cloud Armor, and other
devices on the network.
Next, threat for fraud
detection algorithms
will correlate the
various telemetry
and generate additional
signatures of malicious traffic
to block upstream.
These signatures can then
be dynamically pushed
into the Cloud Armor
security policy as a new rule
to quickly block the newly
detected malicious behavior,
all at the edge of
Google's network.
With that, I wanted to thank
you for joining me today.
If you have any other
questions, please check out
our recently published
blogs or the product page.
And don't hesitate to reach out
with any detailed questions,
and we'd be happy to
follow up with you.
Thank you.